alguna vez te has preguntado qué es lo
que realmente hace un químico en esta
serie pedimos a personas con formación
en química que nos compartieran sus
historias tenemos personas de todos los
campos y carreras por ejemplo tenemos
una entrevista de alguien que trabaja en
ciencia forense que está estrechamente
relacionada con la química analítica
también tenemos personas del campo de la
ilustración científica y de medicina si
alguna vez has pensado en estudiar pre
medicina o cualquier otra cosa
relacionada con la medicina
probablemente ya sabes que deberás tomar
un buen número de clases de química
tenemos a alguien que trabaja en la
industria como investigador
desarrollando nuevos productos también
tenemos a alguien que trabaja como
programador en khan academy en realidad
tenemos muchas otras entrevistas sobre
carreras de las que fue un poco más
difícil encontrar fotos pero todos son
trabajos realmente geniales hemos
cubierto otros campos como la ley de
patentes y la ciencia en los medios de
comunicación que incluye cosas como
hacer
reducir y presentar programas de
televisión sobre ciencia tenemos una
ingeniera que no era experta en química
pero que tomó algunas clases de química
y la terminó usando en su trabajo
tenemos una epidemióloga que también es
una carrera realmente interesante y más
esperamos seguir agregando entrevistas a
esta colección a lo largo del tiempo así
que por favor regresa a consultar espero
que puedas notar en esta lista que todas
estas personas que estudiaron química
están haciendo muchas cosas diferentes
de modo que hay muchas maneras de usar
la química como parte de tu carrera
después de la escuela esperamos que
estas entrevistas sean interesantes y
útiles para descubrir qué carrera
quieres estudiar